DAMIEN MABIN: So I am Damien.
I am a developer advocate for
video games here at Google.
And before that, I have
been doing games development
for about eight years.
We all try to build
games that are unique.
games that are special.
And yet they all have one common
point-- they all have bugs.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about how to handle them,
especially on Android.
Android is well-known for
being a platform where
apps are made in Java.
Making games is
mostly C++'s job,
although some game engines use
scripting languages, like C#.
In most cases, either you
are working with C++ directly
or with a scripting
language debugging bugs.
And Android can be a challenge.
So let's see how we
can make that fairly--
a little bit easier.
There are three
parts in fixing bugs.
The first one is
obviously collecting them.
If you don't know about the
bug, and if they are not
properly clustered, you
can't really fix them.
After you have your
collection of bugs,
you need to find out which
one you should be fixing next.
It's rare that
someone has the time
to fix every single
bug out there.
And finally, you need to
get done with it and fix it.
So let's see, a little bit,
how the collection part works.
While you are
developing your game,
there is multiple staging in it,
obviously, during development.
You will likely be
using a debug build.
And hopefully you are
used to adb logcat
so you can collect
the bugs through that.
Then later, during
QA, mostly, you
will be using a release build.
And also, you will have
access to adb and logcat.
And finally, during
production, it's
a slightly different
story, right?
Because your user out there
will not connect a USB cable,
install a Android SDK, launch
adb, and send you a stack trace
by email.
So you are going to have
to rely on Android vitals
or Crashlytics to get the
stack trace back to you.
OK, let's start
with development.
There is a little bit
of text on the slide.
Sometimes it's a
little bit small.
Don't read it too much.
So that's what you
get out of logcat
get right when you debug--
when you have a crash
in the debuggable build,
a build that contained
the bugs in [INAUDIBLE]..
Pretty much, right away, it
gives you all the information
you need, right?
I think if you have read that
multiple times in the past,
you can see that
it's a signal 11.
You can see that
there is, somewhere,
someone that is freeing a
pointer that has already been
freed before, or not allocated.
Who knows?
And if you look at
the bottom part,
you can see that there
is a function called
MainActivity_button2 that is
calling another function called
hdr_record_value, in turn,
calling hdr_record_values.
And somewhere it's crashing
in counts_index_for.
Well, that's quite nice to
understand which function
is crashing right
away without having
to do much more work than
looking at your logcat.
During QA, that stack
trace turned out into that.
That's a little bit less digest.
You get function address.
And I'm not so good with
understanding that 841e should
be some name for a C++ function.
So we will see, a little bit--
we'll see, just
after that, how you
can take that stack
trace and symbolicate it
so that you have the real name
and even the line of code that
is crashing.
And if you look at production,
well, in production,
when you launch--
sorry, in production, when you
launch a-- oh no, sorry, wait,
there is actually no
adb in production.
So in production, you will
have to use either Crashlytics
or Android vitals.
So I think you already
heard about both of them
earlier today.
I'm just going to quickly
brush through the difference
between each of these.
So Android vitals is
pretty much out-of-the-box.
If you publish a
game on Play Store,
and you go in the Play
Developer Console,
and you look at the
Android vitals section,
you will see, right
away, your crashes.
And the crashes
there will already
contain the stack trace.
However the stack trace
is not symbolicated,
so you will just have--
as we had during AQ
with the release build--
you will just have the
C++ function address.
If you look at Crashlytics
on the other side,
Crashlytics will call
your own SDK integration.
So if you haven't integrated
it, obviously, it's not working.
It's cross-platform--
iOS, Android--
and supports Java,
C++, and Unity.
And it will symbolicate
the stack trace right away
in Crashlytics console.
So if you go there and you
look at your stack traces,
you will already have the
name of the function where--
of the stack as well as the
line where it's crashing.
There is one little
detail in Android vitals
that makes it slightly unique.
It's that it uploads
the crash independently
from your game execution.
It's really important
for one reason--
the worst crash you can have in
a game is when you launch it,
and it's crashing right away.
And you try to launch it
again, and it's crashing again.
If you are in the boot
loop-- in a crash that
happened during the
boot, it's very difficult
to detect if you are relying
on SDK being integrated.
Because the SDK will
upload the crash while
the game is running.
But if its crashing
at start, there
is no way for the SDK
to upload the crash.
Android vitals,
however-- what happened
is that your game
crashed during the boot.
The crash is being--
the stack trace
is being registered by
the OS, by Android itself.
And Play Store will
upload it later.
So even if you have a crash
that happened during boot,
Android vitals will surface it.
It makes it very unique.
OK, so now let's see how it
looks like for Android vitals.
As I was saying earlier,
it doesn't symbolicate
the stack trace, which
means that you will
have to do some manual work.
The first thing is,
go in Android vitals,
copy the stack trace.
The second thing is, when
you compile your game,
you need to keep
the debug symbol
and store it somewhere in
your favorite file system.
And after that, you will
use an [INAUDIBLE] table
called ndk-stack that is
part of the Android NDK.
And with the stack trace
plus the debug symbol,
you will be able to
symbolicate the stack trace.
And once you did that once, you
just repeat with the next bug.
Let's see how it looks like.
You go in Android vitals.
You can see that, in
this simple game I made,
there is two crashes, one
that says, "New in version 4."
if you click on
that one, you can
see the highlighted
blue part at the bottom.
That is the stack trace.
As you can see there,
the stack trace
doesn't contain any
name for any function.
So you copy-paste
that stack trace
wherever you want in a text file
in your development machine.
And then you use ndk-stack,
that is part of the Android NDK,
with your debug
symbol on one side.
And the last part
of the argument
will be the text file
containing the stack trace.
And what you get out
of it is a lot of text.
Let's zoom a little bit.
So that's what I had in
my text file originally.
You can see, pretty much
no information for a human.
And what you get after executing
ndk-stack is quite a lot
better.
You can see that it's
crashing in Game.cpp,
line 26 when it's indicating a
function called Button2() that
is, itself, calling a
function in Game.cpp,
line 31 calling
TrackStats(), and et cetera.
You can see that, at the end,
it's crashing in a function
called hdr_record_value,
line 404.
Hopefully you can find 404.
OK, let's see, now, how it
looks like in Crashlytics.
In Crashlytics,
it's a lot easier.
As I was saying earlier,
in Crashlytics console,
you will already have this
stack trace being symbolicated.
So right away, you can
see that, for this craft,
it is a little bit different
from the previous one.
It's crashing line 104
of hdr_histogram.c.
So that helps you
pinpoint exactly where
the crash happened.
Now that you know exactly
where the crash happened,
how do you prioritize them?
90% of the time, when I look at
games that people haven't been
too careful about crashes
in the past, what I see
is this kind of separation.
I see, on the right side,
the blue part, very few bugs
that impact a lot of users.
Obviously, these ones are very
important to fix right now.
And the green ones are
somewhat medium amount
of crashes that impact
quite some users,
but not nearly as
many as the blue one.
And obviously, you will have
a lot of bugs that impact very
few users.
So it's easy to
prioritize the blue ones
if there is five of them.
But what happens if
there is 100 of them?
Or what happens if you
have very few blue ones
that you can fix very quickly,
but you have 500 green ones.
So let's see how you
can prioritize them.
I think the secret there lies
into planning for the future.
And you need to ask yourself
three questions to plan
for the future of your game
in the coming months or years.
The first one is how--
to understand the future,
it's nice to understand
where you are now.
So understand how many impacted
users exist right now for one
specific cluster of game--
of crash.
Once you know how many users
are impacted, you need to think,
are these users growing in
size or decreasing in size?
A good example is,
maybe all these users
are using an old
version of Android that
is decreasing in popularity.
So maybe this crash will resolve
by itself if you wait a week.
Or maybe they are all
happening on Android 8.0,
and it's growing over months.
So it's going to be
worse in a month.
And finally, it's
really important
to try and understand,
based on where
the crash is
happening, when does
it happen in the user session.
If it happened very early
on, it's probably really bad.
If it happened after 15
minutes of gameplay, maybe
the user will just
relaunch the game.
So let's see, a bit, how you
can understand better if it's
going to grow or decrease--
for one specific bug,
if it's going to occur
more or less in a month.
If you go in Android vitals,
you have this information
for your game right away.
That gives you, for
each version of Android,
how many weekly active
users you have--
sorry, in this case, it's
monthly active users.
And it gives you how it
compared to the previous month.
So there you can see
that 8.0 had 7,500 users.
And it increased by 4.7%
compared to previous month.
And you can see that for
each version of Android.
I find that a little
bit hard to read,
so I usually extract
it in that format.
For each version of Android,
I have the amount of users
and if it's increasing
or decreasing
in amount month over month.
So I highlight, in red,
the version of Android
I care the most about.
And I highlight,
in green, the one
that I care a bit less about.
And then I take each crash--
that's one crash-- and I look
at which-- from Android vitals--
and I look at which Android
versions are impacted.
In this one, I just put
some circles on it that
reflect the color on the left.
And you can see that
Android 8.0 is there.
7.0 is there.
That crash is probably
somewhat important.
However, there are crashes.
And I'm pretty sure you
have some in your game
that are much worse.
That's a crash that
was in one of my games.
It impacted only--
all the crashes--
all the occurrences
of this crash
happened on Android 8.0 users.
And if you see, over the
last month, Android 8.0,
I had 7,500 users.
This crash happened 7,400
times over the last month.
I am not sure if it's a
one-to-one relationship
between users and crashes,
but it's pretty close.
So I would say nearly all my
Android 8.0 users are impacted.
And this crash, month over
month, is going to grow by 5%,
more or less.
So it's really important
for me to focus my time
on fixing that crash,
although the number
of occurrences of
this crash might
be a bit lower than others.
If you look at
some other crashes,
sometimes it's a lot easier.
This one, well, there is
only one Android 7.0 crash
that really matters there.
So maybe it's not
super high-priority.
Because month over
month, this crash
will decrease in
occurrences by 5%.
OK, so now that we see
how you collect crashes,
and you have a bit of an idea
how you prioritize them, well,
for fixing them, there
is really no trick there.
Sadly, that's your job.
I can't really help.
It's really game-specific there.
So let's recap a
little bit for today.
There is three
things I really want
you to remember from this talk.
First one is please
keep the debug symbol.
How many times I have seen
the developers, at launch,
in an APK have critical crashes,
and didn't keep the debug
symbol, and is left over
with stack traces that
contain function addresses
and no way how to read them.
It's quite sad.
So even if it's
just by pure safety
because your game has
zero crashes right now,
every time you compile an
APK, keep the debug symbol.
If you don't know how
to get the debug symbol,
you can search for it.
It's really not that difficult.
Second thing is Android vitals--
even if you don't care
about your crashes too much,
go take a look at
Android vitals.
It will help you understand
how bad the problem is.
The truth is that,
hopefully, the problem is not
so bad for you,
and you don't need
to focus too much time on it.
But maybe you will find
out that your users are
having 5% crashes every day.
And in that case,
Android vitals will
be able to help you
understand if you
need the help of Crashlytics
to debug all these crashes.
As I showed earlier, Android
vitals plus ndk-stack
can be a little bit cumbersome
to work with the stack traces,
but it works.
If you see that you have
50 crashes, that's fine.
If you have 500, maybe
you want to think
into getting Crashlytics
so that it symbolicates
the stack trace right away.
And finally, well,
now that you know
that there is a way to fix your
crashes in your game, well,
you should really come to
the next session, where
Bill will talk about
how you optimize
the performance of your game.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL BILODEAU: Thanks, Damien.
So let's talk a little
bit about why you might
want to optimize your game.
One of the obvious reasons is
to get better-looking games.
Who here doesn't want
their game to look better?
Now with all that extra
rendering you need to do,
you'll have to optimize the
game to still make it run fast.
Another reason is to make
the game more responsive.
And this is important
for games that
are very competitive,
like multiplayer games,
or games that require quick
response time because they're
fast-paced games.
You should also
optimize for memory.
Because you don't want
your game crashing
because it runs out of memory.
And you should consider
optimizing for power.
Because these are
mobile devices.
They have a battery.
And you want the players
to be able to play
the game a long time without
running down the battery.
The other reason is because
power is related to heat.
And when the device
heats up, the system
will throttle the CPU, which
will cause it to run slower.
So let's look at some CPU
performance optimizations.
One of the best things you can
do is to do multithreading.
So high-end Android
devices have eight cores.
And it's really a waste to just
not use some of those cores.
A single-threaded core--
single-threaded game
is a waste.
So one of the things we know
is that multithreading--
and of course, concurrent
multithreading,
which is really the optimal
way of doing multithreading--
has better performance per
watt than single-threading.
So it affects perform--
affects power as well.
You've probably all heard
that it's good to batch.
And this is still true.
Every draw call has
overhead with it,
driver overhead with it.
So if you can combine draw
calls into a single draw call,
that's going to help
with that CPU overhead.
Game engines like
Unity, they have
options for doing dynamic
and static batching, which
can help with that.
The other thing you want
to do is not draw things
that you're not going to see.
So things like frustrum
culling and occlusion culling
are important.
Vulkan is a good API for
reducing the draw call
overhead.
The Vulkan API doesn't
require validation
being done for every draw call.
And that's how it saves time.
The other thing that's good
about Vulkan is you can do--
you can build command buffers
using multiple threads.
And so now this takes
advantage of multithreading,
as I mentioned earlier.
You don't want to
overlook loading times.
The reason is
because loading times
can affect if your
players are going
to continue to play the game.
If it takes too long
to load the game,
it may not be worth it to them.
So some of the things you can
do to improve loading time
include, just pick a
good compression format--
so one that decompresses fast.
An example could be LZ4.
The other thing you want to
do is only load what you need.
You don't want to
load the entire level
when you're only going to be--
sorry, you don't want to
load the entire game when
you're only playing one level.
The other thing you should
do is to hide the loading.
So even though you're
still loading the game,
you don't want to
make it obvious,
like having a big loading
bar like in this diagram.
So something you
could do is like, when
the user is navigating
through the menus,
you can load things
in the background.
And for Unity,
IL2CPP has been shown
to have really good performance.
So even for not just loading,
general CPU performance,
you should IL2CPP.
So we're going to
be asking developers
to use 64-bit and have a
64-bit version of their APK
later this year.
And this is also a good thing,
because 64-bit gives you
better performance.
It can because the 64-bit
instruction set has access
to twice as many registers
as a 32-bit instruction set,
even though they're
running on the same device.
Because of this,
the compiler can
use those registers to
do better optimizations
and make your code run faster.
So now let's take a look
at the GPU side of things.
One of the most common reasons
for a game to be GPU-bound
and to spend a lot
of time on a GPU
is when it spends time
in the fragment shaders.
So the more pixels
you're rendering,
the more time it's
going to take.
Now modern devices, they have
incredibly dense displays.
And so it's really
overkill for most games.
You can render a game at
a much lower resolution,
and it'll still look just fine.
Now you might be
thinking that, well,
when I render it at
a lower resolution,
the problem is the text
starts to look blurry.
Well, a couple of
things you can do--
one is you can
reduce the resolution
in one dimension, just either
vertically or horizontally.
That can help.
Another thing you
can do is you can
render the text, or the HUD,
at full-screen resolution
and composite it with the
lower-resolution version.
Now you can do this
in a fragment shader.
For example, if you're doing
post-processing anyway,
what you can do is combine
that with the upscaling
and the compositing.
And then in one step, you
can get that combined.
The other thing you
can do in some cases
is to use the hardware composer.
All Android devices
have hardware composers
that can composite
multiple layers of images.
So if it's not fill-rate-bound
and pixel-shader-bound,
it's the other end,
which is geometry-bound.
So you want to reduce
the number of vertices.
And the way to do this,
the common way to do this,
is, of course, to use LODs.
Now some GPUs are more
capable than others.
So what you can do is adjust
that LOD distance based
on the capability of the GPU.
So higher-end GPUs, you can
extend that high-detailed LOD
out further.
The other thing you can do
is take that to the extreme
and have imposters, which are
just 2D geometry with textures
to represent 3D geometry.
And when something is far out
in the distance, it looks fine.
So now, getting back
to responsiveness,
the important thing
about responsiveness
is consistent responsiveness.
One of the things that happens
is, if that responsiveness
is not consistent, if that
touch latency isn't consistent,
the game just kind
of feels wrong.
Like, it has a bad feel to it.
Here's an example of a game
that was captured with systrace.
And you can see the actual frame
times for individual frames.
Some of the frames are fast.
Some are slow.
But interestingly,
it all averages out
to 30 frames per second.
So if all of your--
if the only thing
that you're measuring
is average frames
per second, this
could be completely overlooked.
With Android, one of
the things you can do
is use the choreographer API.
And this allows you
to register callbacks
that happen every
Vsync, which you can use
to synchronize your rendering.
Now, you want to
optimize for power,
as I said, because it's
important on mobile devices.
Some games really do work better
with 60 frames per second.
But most games-- you know,
slower-paced games that
aren't fighting games
or something like that--
they can run well at
30 frames per second.
So even if your game can
run at 60 frames per second,
it's better for it to
run at 30 because you're
saving so much power.
You're doing half as much work.
Also you want to consider
offloading things to the GPU.
The reason is the GPU
is more power-efficient.
It does more things in
parallel than the CPU.
an example could
be doing animation
on the GPU like GPU skinning.
Thread affinity is a
great way to manage power.
Linux gives you the
ability to manage threads
with thread affinity.
And as you can see
in this example,
you don't want to schedule
all of your threads
necessarily on the big cores.
The big cores are typically
cores four through seven.
The little cores are the first
cores, zero through three.
The little cores aren't
as fast, but they
are more power-efficient.
So if you had something-- a
thread, say, for example--
that wasn't really
performance-critical,
and say it was doing something
like asynchronous loading
for streaming assets
for future frames,
then you could
probably put something
like that on a little core.
So now let's look at memory.
Optimizing for memory can be
difficult on mobile devices.
One of the reasons
is you're not always
sure how much memory you
have available to you.
Because you're sharing the
memory with the system,
with other apps.
And so you can't expect to use
all of that physical memory.
So let's take a look
at this, for example.
This is a Pixel 3.
And it has 1.6 gigabytes
for system memory--
that's used by the system.
Now, you can't expect
to evict all that memory
and use it all for your game.
So on a 4-gigabyte
system, in this case,
you might be able to use
2 gigabytes of memory.
Now, if you want to reduce
the amount of memory
that your game is using,
one of the things you can do
is use a shader cache.
The shade cache--
an LRU shader cache
is actually used by
the Unreal Engine.
So you could use that feature.
So the way it works is you can
make sure that only the shaders
that you're interested
in, that you're using,
are cached in the GPU memory.
OpenGL with Vulkan, both,
you can extract shaders
from the GPU memory,
compress the binaries,
and store them in CPU memory.
Now you're trading off
GPU memory for CPU memory.
But that's OK, because it's
all the same physical memory,
because it's a unified
memory architecture.
And finally, for testing memory,
one thing you want to consider
is testing on
real-world situations.
For example, you want
to test on devices which
have a lot of apps installed.
We found that when you
have some apps installed,
they can take up memory, even
though you may not expect that.
So you don't want to
test on a clean device.
DANIEL GALPIN: So I'm
here for the comic relief
part of our day.
And this talk is about
rogue permissions.
And I'm sure you're wondering
exactly what that really means.
And so I have a visual aid.
And essentially, what we're
about here is what happens--
you know, when you're
writing a game,
much of the code that is
actually going into your game
is stuff that you
actually haven't written.
And so rogue permissions,
in this case--
DANIEL GALPIN (PIRATE
ACCENT): --are permissions
that are not used
by the game itself,
but are instead used by
the libraries and tools
that your game depends on.
So for this talk,
"rogue" really refers
to code that you didn't write.
And I probably should
have entitled it
something like, you know,
"Be wary of rogue code,"
but I digress.
And you're also
probably wondering,
am I to keep this accent
for the rest of the talk?
And the answer is, I will not.
DANIEL GALPIN: So what
I wanted to point out
here is that when we're
talking about these things,
we are talking about this
combination of privacy
and performance equals
policy-- or to alliterate,
we passionately
pledge to promote
privacy and performance, which
leads to pertinent policy.
And an example of
this, when you're
looking at a library
or SDK, you really
need to be asking yourself
a bunch of questions.
One is, does this library
or SDK actually want
unnecessary access
to sensitive data?
And the second thing
is, what impact
does it have on the app
performance, or even worse,
on system health in general?
And so let's say
something that a--
DANIEL GALPIN (PIRATE ACCENT):
--possibly rogue code--
DANIEL GALPIN: --might need
is the location permission.
Now first of all, there's
two types of location
that it might need.
There's course location
and find location.
And honestly, to your game,
it really doesn't matter.
Because on Android M,
they're both kind of bad.
Because you end up having to
pop up this runtime permission,
and it's really terrible.
And most likely,
your libraries aren't
going to be needing
this because of that.
But if they do, it's
really important.
Because users need
to be informed
that not only is this app able
to track sensitive information,
such as their location,
but also that the device
is likely to drain their
battery much faster.
A-ha, and in Android
O, we actually
attempted to mitigate
some of the battery drain
problems with
location by limiting
how often background
apps actually get access
to this location data.
And we honestly still
have more work to do here.
So the moral of this
story, so to speak,
is that location, as an
example, is an intersection
of performance and privacy.
And this influences both the way
that the Play Store as well as
the platform look at policy.
So again, there's a whole
bunch of these permissions.
And if you need to
get access to any
of these kind of
sensitive permissions,
you really need to understand
why this is happening.
It's very, very important.
Now one of the things
you should look for
is that Android library
projects, these--
DANIEL GALPIN (PIRATE
ACCENT): --SDKs and tools--
DANIEL GALPIN: --can
include library permissions.
So they actually have their
own Android manifests.
And once again, we can use
our favorite tool, the APK
Analyzer, to actually look
at all of the permissions
that your app is actually
going to end up requesting.
And it's really
important, again,
for you to understand why
your game ends up requesting
each one of these permissions.
Now plugins also are libraries.
And so they can also contain
permissions in native code.
So we to make sure
they're also compliant.
And finally, we
want to make sure
that you are testing with
the latest target SDK.
These things are important.
If you saw in
Damien's talk earlier,
you can actually
end up with crashes
that only impact certain SDKs.
So you want to make sure
everything works as expected.
So you can use things
like Play test tracks,
which are very, very useful.
And now for something that can
also be a real problem for code
that you don't write,
and that is 64-bit.
And now I know
what you're saying.
You know, you're
thinking, OK, this
has nothing to do
with permissions.
I'm totally going off
the reservation here.
But it really is
something you have
to think about when
choosing a library or SDK.
And besides, we know, from the
history of video game console
marketing, that
64-bit is just cool.
So moving to 64-bit
will actually
make your APK size larger.
But it will also typically
make your game run faster.
And there's lots of
reasons for that.
The 64-bit instruction
set was actually
designed for performance
over things like code
size and other things.
And it actually has
double the registers.
But more importantly,
it actually
does things like supports
double precision floating
point in neon code.
So your compiler can actually
do really clever vectorization
and really, really improve
the performance of a lot
of heavy floating point stuff.
And you know, it just turns
out that games actually
take a lot of advantage
of floating point.
So the good news is
that this won't actually
make your APK size that much
larger, having a 64-bit binary,
if you move to
Android app bundles.
We've talked about
these a whole bunch.
These are great, because
it actually strips out
the unnecessary binaries
when you distribute
your game with an app bundle and
using Google Play app signing.
So if you have a 32-bit and
a 64-bit binary in your app,
the device will only get
the one that it actually
needs the most.
And while you're at
it, you can do things
like bundling x86 and
x86-64 support with no size
penalty to your ARM apps.
And these versions will
actually work better
on a lot of Chrome OS devices.
So with performance
implications,
this has, of course,
become a Google Play policy
decision, at least initially.
So by this August, all
new and updated games
must include a 64-bit version.
Now there is an
exception for Unity
when targeting
Unity 5.6 or less.
Google Play will
continue to allow
updating games built with
these older Unity versions
for another two years.
And then it won't
deliver any 32-bit games
to any 64-bit-capable devices.
Please do not go out and import
your games back to Unity 5.6.
There's a lot of really
good reasons to actually run
the newer versions of Unity.
Now of course, Google also
hasn't made any guarantee that
we're actually going to have
non-64-bit-only devices by this
point either.
And note that you need 27.4.16
if you want to run 64-bit code,
or 2018.2 or higher.
Because 64-bit was actually
ported back to 2017.4.16.
Another thing
you'll need to do is
switch to the IL2CPP back end.
And that'll mostly make
your game run faster.
So it's actually a win-win.
So some tips for
going to 64-bit--
one is that, once again, you can
use our favorite tool, the APK
analyzer, to see what 32-bit
dependencies you might have.
And you can examine all the
files in the lib folder.
The 32-bit libraries
or in the armeabi-v7a--
or even v5, if you still have
them-- and x86 directories.
Next, you can do a 64-bit build.
So you know, Cocos, and
Unreal, and Unity all
support 64-bit code on Android
with the correct settings.
And also, Gradle,
CMake, and ndk-build
can easily add 64-bit targets.
Now obviously,
there's a lot of work
that you do have
to do to make sure
that everything in
your native code
is going to work
correctly with 64-bit.
I'm under the assumption
that since many of you
do publish on other
64-bit platforms,
that most of this code and this
work has already been done.
But there is
definitely some work
to make sure that you are doing
all the right things in 64-bit.
You also may need to
upgrade SDKs and libraries
to more recent versions.
And this is an opportunity to
reach out to library owners
if there are 64-bit-ready
versions that aren't available.
And this is also
a really good time
to examine the real need for all
of these external dependencies.
It's amazing to see,
when you actually
go through an audit, all of
the things that are in a game.
All of a sudden, it's like, oh,
my APK size is now 20% smaller.
Because it turns out we didn't
really need this anymore.
So it's really good to go back
and do this on a regular basis,
and take a look at all the stuff
you're putting into your APKs.
And finally, there is testing.
You'll want to test locally.
This is another great example
of using Google Play's test
tracks.
You'd also take
advantage of things,
once you're doing this, like
Android vitals and Crashlytics.
All these things can help
you get a really good idea
of how your game is actually
performing in the real world.
Now, once you've
actually tested this,
you can leverage staged
rollouts to make sure
that your users have the
smoothest experience.
So again, there's
a lot of things
you can do to test this to
make this experience great.
Again, mostly 64-bit should
be a win-win for both you
and your users--
so four straightforward steps
to get your game to 64-bit.
Now there is a
moral to this story.
And that is, performance matters
to us, and hopefully, to you.
And it's something
you should consider
when choosing any
code that you didn't
write to ship with your game.
So when you're
examining whether or not
to use a new
library or SDK, make
sure that it works
with a true 64-bit app.
Another thing to think about
is API-level targeting.
Now, for an app or
game to be permitted
to update on Google
Play, it needs
to target the latest
Android release
within a year of its release.
Now currently, that means
targeting 2017's Oreo,
but not for much longer.
Because as of August,
it will actually
mean targeting 2018's Pie.
And you need to make sure
that any library or SDK
that your game
depends upon actually
supports targeting the
latest API release.
And this is important,
because there actually
are some Android
behavior changes that are
tied to the target SDK version.
Now Android, in many
cases, actually preserves
some out-of-date
functionality for apps
that are targeting older SDK
versions for the purposes
of compatibility.
Now, libraries and
SDKs can also do things
like impacting launch speed.
You can often mitigate
this, of course,
by deferring lowering
of these libraries.
But some libraries
will do things
like requiring initialization
in the application class, which
gets initialized before
most of your code.
Or less obviously, they'll
even contain a content provider
that makes sure that
the app is initialized
before even the
libraries-- excuse me,
is even initialized even before
the application code runs.
And this is really only
a reasonable solution
if you're doing things
like crash analytics.
Because obviously, you
want your crash provider
to be initialized
very, very early.
And there we are.
Fortunately, you can
use the systrace tool
to profile your launch speed
and see the impacts of libraries
and SDKs.
Now sometimes, you might have
so much data coming in here
that, actually, systrace
isn't a great tool for that.
So you can also
leverage simpleperf.
Launching faster, as
we have said before,
means your game will
likely be played more.
and with any luck, that'll
translate into dollars.
And we've got some
great videos on YouTube
that show how to use systrace
to optimize launch speed
and profile other
performance problems.
Now Google Play has
its own policies.
And you need to make sure
that the library doesn't
violate those.
And this is because
Google Play really
does have a critical role
in protecting the privacy
and safety of Android devices.
As an example,
apps aren't allowed
to sideload code changes.
Google Play has actually
had to unpublish apps
when SDK providers
have done things
that violate Play policies.
And of course,
multiple violations
get an account banned from Play.
So this is really
important stuff.
And then there are things
that I have absolutely
no ability whatsoever to advise
you on, other than I strongly
do encourage you to make sure
that code that you don't write
is compliant with all
necessary policies
and regulations from various
entities around the world.
And of course, you
should test the library
against the latest
Android version you can,
such as our recently
released Q beta.
These are all of the desserts
I could find that begin with Q.
And Q actually
makes changes that
continue to improve Android's
speed, privacy, and safety.
Now, it continues
our work on location
by actually giving the user
an option to allow a game
or app to only access location
when in the foreground.
It also limits access to device
and hardware identifiers,
such as IMEI, or
serial number, IMSI.
And it actually
automatically randomizes
MAC address across
different Wi-Fi networks.
And this is important.
Because a lot of
ads in analytics
packages may not
function correctly
if they weren't already using
the appropriate identifiers.
And of course, Q is
bringing a whole bunch
of updates around
performance, including--
very exciting to me--
support for Vulkan 1.1.
We are also doing
something kind of cool.
I don't know if you've noticed
this in our announcement.
We're actually supporting,
experimentally,
OpenGLES 2.0 running
on top of Vulkan
through the ANGLE project.
And this is great.
It's not really going
to affect performance.
But we hope it will actually
lead, in the long term,
to more stable OpenGL drivers
and more stable Vulkan drivers.
And we're also doing
this really cool thing
in Q called cloud-based,
profile-guided optimizations
for ART.
So this means that code
that's actually running inside
of managed code on
your app will actually
get profiled and optimized more
quickly, which, of course, just
means that your users are going
to see better performance more
quickly.
And of course, the
best thing you can do
is to test your game
against the current beta.
Try running your current build.
And consider running
a build that actually
targets the Android Q SDK.
And you can find
out all about this
at google.com/android/beta.
And right now, we're currently
supporting Pixel, and Pixel 2,
and Pixel 3, and the various
XL versions of all of them.
So at least this is a
good start with devices.
And you can sign up right there.
And we will deliver the beta
to your device wirelessly.
And that's it.
So here's a bunch of
resources to find out
about getting your
apps ready for 64-bit
as well as some best practices
around that, and of course,
the beta.
Up next is our
final talk from Ben
about how you can extend
your games beyond mobile.
[APPLAUSE]
BEN GABLE: As Dan
mentioned, I'm Ben Gable.
I'm a partner developer
advocate at Google
working with game developers.
And today, I'm going to
be talking about extending
Android games beyond mobile.
And what do I mean by that?
So-- whoops, that's
the laser button.
So mobile gaming is evolving.
And just a few years
ago, mobile gaming
used to mean games you
play on your phone.
But now it's not
so clear anymore.
The Android ecosystem
is evolving.
And Android now runs
not only on phones,
but on tablets, desktop
extension devices like Chrome
OS and Samsung DeX,
and coming very soon,
the exciting world of foldables
like the Samsung Galaxy Fold.
So maybe just a quick
question for the crowd--
how many of you
have purposefully
optimized your game for
a device that's not just
a mobile device?
Show of hands, anybody?
I see, like, two hands.
OK, how many of you are actually
planning on maybe, this year,
with your next game, adapting
your Android game for a device
that's not just mobile?
Anybody?
OK, a few more
hands-- so hopefully,
at the end of this talk, there's
a lot more hands that go up.
But the key point that I
want to drive home here
is that, as game
developers, you need
to consider that
your game is not just
going to be being played
on mobile devices anymore.
Players might be playing it
on a phone in a portrait mode.
They might be playing
on a Chromebook or DeX
with a keyboard and
mouse attached to it.
They could be
playing on a foldable
with multiple displays.
So when they switch open
from the small screen
to the large screen, the
resolution and aspect ratio
changes.
This is really important, to
start thinking about this.
Because as game
developers, you guys
want to provide the best
possible gaming experience
for your players no
matter what device
they happen to be
experiencing your game on.
Now I realize that the
words "new platform"
or "supporting an
additional platform"
is kind of scary for
a lot of developers.
But what I really
want to stress here
is that this is
all still Android.
And by following the
Android best practices,
you're going to get a
great baseline experience
and compatibility across
all these different devices.
So certainly there's things you
can add specific to foldables,
or tablets, or Chrome OS.
But I really want to
focus on the core things,
the stuff in the middle there.
That's going to give you a
great experience with the least
amount of work.
And hopefully, I've boiled
it down to three main areas
you need to consider.
And that is screen
considerations,
input considerations, and how
to build and set up your APK
so that when it's
distributed, it can support
the most devices possible.
So let's start off with
talking about some screen
considerations.
What do I mean by that?
So when your game is launched
on some of these other devices,
like a Chromebook or
Samsung DeX, by default,
your game is going
to be launched
in a windowed environment where
it can be dynamically resized.
And on foldables, it'll be
launched in an environment
where, if the user
opens the device up
from the smaller screen to
the larger internal screen,
the aspect ratio and
resolution is going to change.
So the most important
thing here to support
is what we call
configuration changes.
And for those of
you that are not
familiar with the idea
of configuration changes,
basically, the Android system
will restart an activity
every time it detects
that something
has changed about
the environment
that your game is running in.
By default, the system does
this automatically by invoking
onSaveInstanceState() before
your activity is restarted.
However, for a lot of
resource-heavy games,
this is not the best approach.
It can be really slow.
And especially in the cases of
things like dynamic resizing,
where you could be getting
configuration change
events every frame,
it just doesn't work.
So what we recommend
as a best practice is
to handle these configuration
changes yourself.
And you can do so really easily
by, inside your manifest,
declaring all of the
configuration changes
that you want to handle in code.
So in this example,
we've said we
want to handle screen size and
orientation changes ourselves.
So then, once you declare all
the configuration changes that
you want to support, inside
onConfigurationChanged()
in your activity, you can--
whenever that change happens,
you now get an event.
And you can handle
whatever that change was.
So for example, you could
scale your OpenGL content
to match the new resolution
or the aspect ratio
to prevent things like
inaccessible UI elements
or input areas that
don't make sense anymore
with the new resolution
of your game.
And if your game is
always intended to be run
in full-screen for example, or
maybe you've got some bugs you
need to quickly iron them out,
you can always prevent resizing
by specifying
resizeableActivity="false"
in your manifest.
But keep in mind that this will
prevent split-screen operations
of your game.
And we don't really
recommend it,
because it is a
valid user experience
to have your game running
with Twitch chat or something
else in those kinds of
windowed environments.
So we recommend supporting
it whenever you can.
For orientation--
for mobile devices,
orientation is, by
default, portrait.
But on other devices,
it could be landscape.
So it's important to make
sure that-- in your manifest,
the best way to handle and
tell the system what kind
of orientations you support
is to specify your sensor
orientations in your manifest.
Now if you're handling
orientation changes yourself
in code, you want to make
sure that you're using
Display.getRotation(), as that
will give you the accurate
information you need in order
to determine which orientation
the device is in.
But be aware that the
values you're expecting with
Display.getRotation() might
be swapped depending on what
the hardware's default
orientation is.
So just be aware of that.
Also consider the
resolution of the device
that you're playing on.
So a bigger screen
means you should
provide high-resolution assets.
You can use app bundles--
has been mentioned many times
today-- to package all your
assets and have Google Play
deliver only the assets that
are relevant to the device that
your player is playing on--
so for example, emitting
ultra-high-resolution assets
if they're playing
on a mobile device
or only serving up the
ultra-high-resolution assets
they're playing on
something like a Chromebook
or a high-resolution tablet.
This saves you valuable download
space, which is always a win,
and also the trouble of
maintaining multiple APKs
for all these different
screen densities.
And with more pixels
comes greater flexibility
on UI and HUD design.
So if your players are
playing on a larger screen,
consider what kinds of
elements you can expand, add,
change to take advantage
of that particular display.
Also, players tend to sit
farther away from a screen
the bigger it is.
So make sure that all of
your fonts and elements
are identifiable and readable.
Nothing more
frustrating than having
to squint at a large screen.
So that's some screen
considerations.
Let's talk about input now.
So more and more games are
delivering a console or PC-like
experience on mobile.
And more Android
devices are now offering
multiple ways of input.
So although Android has had APIs
around for a while for things
like keyboard, mouse
support, and controllers,
most game developers
just assume that they're
going to be playing
with touch controls.
And that gets really
frustrating when
players download a game that's
been even ported from a PC
or console, and they
try to use a keyboard
or mouse on a Chromebook,
or something like that,
and it doesn't work.
It's a pretty
frustrating experience.
So the other thing
to keep in mind
is that, also, many of these
devices are convertibles.
So they can change between
different configurations
on the fly, such as clamshell
with keyboard to tablet mode.
So it's important to kind
of detect those changes
and support on-the-fly control
schemes that provide the best
user experience at
the time, and try
to anticipate what you
think the users might
be expecting the control scheme
to be at that particular time.
So the best way to do
this, as I mentioned,
is to detect the
hardware that's available
and support a control scheme
that will give players the best
experience.
So to start, you
might declare, again,
support in your manifest
to handle configuration
changes related to
inputs like keyboards
being attached and detached.
And there's many
ways of doing this.
But essentially, you could
then query input manager
whenever that input change is
detected, or at game start-up,
and figure out what
kinds of hardware
are available for
the players to use,
and then switch the
control scheme on the fly
based on that.
Now another key
point to remember
here is that just because
input manager says
that something is available,
it might not be usable.
So it could be like a
Chromebook with a keyboard
that's actually in tablet mode.
So the keyboard's on the
back, and it's not usable.
So again, just keep in mind that
these devices are convertibles
and that your players may switch
between any number of control
inputs at any time.
And if you don't
think keyboard support
makes sense for your
game, fair enough.
But you might consider
that implementing it
will improve the
accessibility of your game
for lots of people.
So some ideas could
be skill key bindings,
menu, player navigation.
If you really
wanted to get fancy,
you could implement
custom key mapping
so players can set up whatever
they want for specific keys
to do certain actions.
So it's all up to you.
We highly recommend
that you do think
of this for players
that are playing
on these devices with keyboards.
And also, if you haven't
implemented controller support
yet, consider that the
standard Android controller
APIs work on devices like
Chromebooks and Samsung Dex
where controllers might
be more widely used.
So we've talked about screen
and input considerations.
So finally, let's talk about
some general considerations
around building and
configuring your APK
to make sure it supports all
these various devices running
Android.
So first off, review
the permissions
that you're asking for.
And determine if you really
need them, as Dan alluded to
in the previous talk.
Some permissions are not
supported on certain devices
like Chrome OS.
So blindly asking for
permissions or features that
aren't supported will
put you in a scenario
where the user will
try to download it
from Google Play on
that device, and it
will show up as not compatible.
And they'll have no idea why.
So it's kind of a bummer.
Good examples of this might
be GPS or SMS permissions.
And what we recommend
is, basically, you
can list these
features or permissions
as not required in the
manifest and then just check,
in code, to see if that's
actually available.
So that way, users
can download it.
And then you, on your
end, inside your code,
dynamically adapt the game
to either use those features
or not depending on what device
the players are playing on.
Also consider the hardware
and performance capabilities
of the different devices
you're running on.
So if you have an automatic
quality control system,
or you have different
performance profiles,
try to set them
up in such a way--
well, first of all, test them
on these different devices,
like Chromebooks, and
tablets, and foldables.
But then consider setting
up different profiles
to take advantage of
all the extra hardware
and performance capabilities
of those devices.
You want to make
sure that players--
when they buy a
bigger device, they're
expecting more
performance out of it.
So make sure that you're
thinking about that.
Additionally, try to
provide an x86 build.
So many Chromebooks
are x86 only.
And while ARM will
still run on them,
you're going to be
incurring the instruction
translation overhead.
And it will degrade
performance a bit.
And for those looking-- for
those of you looking to get
the maximum graphics
performance, again,
we suggest that you use Vulkan,
as they're now supported across
many devices--
at least 1.0-- with 1.1
support coming very soon.
And finally, test across
all these different devices
is probably the biggest
suggestion we can make.
So add test cases that cover
all the additional flows
like resizing, minimizing,
maximizing, switching
between the small
and large screens.
You want to make sure that you
see how your game is behaving
in all these scenarios.
Because you might
only be testing
on a mobile device, and bad
things could be happening.
You can use things like the
Android or Chrome OS emulators
to get a sense of how your
game might behave if you don't
have those devices available.
Or you could use
Firebase Test Lab
to help you automate the
process, since probably,
not a lot of you
are too thrilled
about having to expand
your QA teams to test
all these different devices.
So there are a few
tools out there
that you can use to help
yourself in that area.
So in closing, the thing that
I really want to stress here
is that Android gaming is
not just phones anymore.
Players are
experiencing your game
on a wide variety of
devices and form factors
with different inputs.
And by following these
Android best practices
and spending just a little
bit of time considering
the additional use cases that
players might be coming across,
you can really take
your game beyond mobile
and provide the
best possible gaming
experience for your players.
And they will thank you for it.